ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACT WE ARE CURRY ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN.
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BURNER FOR BATH [inaudible]
BONTA BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU
CHEN DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY [inaudible]
DALY DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER.
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON.
GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY
[inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA.
KAMLAGER-DOVE KILEY LACKEY
LEVINE LIMON.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN THIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRI NORRIS.
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA [inaudible]
RAMEAU'S RADIUS --
THREE OF US ROBERT REAVIS.
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH
[inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER [inaudible]
WAKES.
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
THERE'S A
QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER
[inaudible]
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN.
REVEREND PATTY MOSHE REVENUE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
THIS NEW YEAR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN IS NOW ONLY SEVEN DAYS
OLD.
THAT IS WELCOME IN THE YEAR
AHEAD WITH OPEN MINDS AND WARM
HEART.
THIS TRIED TO REMAIN POSITIVE.
AND EMBRACE EACH NEW DAY AS A
FRESH START.
JUST AS WE ARE EMBRACING A FRESH
START TO THIS NEW YEAR.
WE CAN DO THIS IF WE JUST
REMEMBER WHAT WE ALL KNOW TO BE
TRUE.
WE KNOW THAT FROM THE MOMENT WE
ARE BORN.
THERE IS NO GUARANTEE OF EVEN
ONE DAY OF LIFE.
EACH DAY IS A GIFT NOT TO BE
TAKEN FOR GRANTED. TOO OFTEN WE
TEND TO TAKE FOR GRANTED THE
DAYS WE ARE ABLE TO LIVE.
INTO EASILY WE FAIL TO TRULY
APPRECIATE.
THE PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES GIVE
MEANING TO OUR OWN.
WITH OUR WISDOM EYES OPEN.
WE SEE THAT THERE IS NO
GUARANTEE OF EVEN ONE MORE DAY
OF LIFE.
WITH WITH THEM EYES OPEN.
WE KNOW AGAIN THE EACH DAY WE
AWAKEN.
TO AS A DAY TO BE TREASURED.
AND EVERY CHANCE TO BE WITH
THOSE WE LOVE.
IS ONE TO CHERISH.
IN THE YEAR AHEAD OF US TRY TO
EMBRACE EACH NEW DAY.
WITH OPEN MINDS AND WARM HEARTS.
LET'S TRY TO WAKE UP EACH DAY.
HAPPY TO BE ALIVE.
THE SLEEP EACH NIGHT.
GRATEFUL FOR THE DAY.
NUMBER ONE THE NUMBER SOON WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND OSHITA WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MELENDEZ AS YOU READ THE AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER.
LADIES GERMAN PLEASE JOIN ME IN
OUR FLAG SALUTE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE [inaudible]
SAY -- IS A
LITTLE.
OR THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
MONDAY DECEMBER THIRD 2018% TO
THE PROVISIONS OF THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE HOUR OF TWELVE
O'CLOCK MERIDIAN.
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
REGULAR SESSION OF THE
LEGISLATURE WAS CALLED TO ORDER
BY EACH DOTSON WILSON CHEAPER
BUT THE ASSEMBLY FOR THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN REGULAR
SESSION.
IN CONFORMITY WITH A LOT OF ONLY.
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS.
AT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION A REFERENCE TO
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR.
THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCES FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THE
RAIN AGAIN SALAS [inaudible]
MISTER CALDERON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE WHEN EIGHTEEN A TO
ALLOW.
THE SPEAKER IN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BLOOM LEVINE MELENDEZ AND QUIRK
SILVA TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MELENDEZ IN
COURTS OF HIS GUESTS WILL BE
SEATED AT THE DESK ALONG WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT.
FIVE AND ALLOW THE SPEAKER AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GALLAGHER DALLY
AND FRAZIER TO SPEAK ON AN
INTERNMENT IN MEMORY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS MAY HAVE YOUR ATTENTION.
WE HAVE SPECIAL GAS IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY.
MS MELENDEZ HAS SOME VIP'S ON
THE FLOOR AT HER DESK MISS
MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
COLLEAGUES I HAVE WITH ME TODAY
TO THE FIVE MELENDEZ CLAN BOYS
WANT TO STAND UP OUR YOUNGEST.
CARLO IS THE SHORT ONE WITH THE
BIG HAIR AND OUR SECOND OLDEST
IS FOLLOW I HE'S A FRESHMAN IN
COLLEGE CARLOS IN MIDDLE SCHOOL.
THIS ONE IS THINKING ABOUT GOING
INTO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THIS ONE SAYS HE'S GOING TO
PLAY FOR THE NFL IN THE NBA
SOUND.
YOU KNOW ANYWAY PLEASE WELCOME
INTO THE CHAMBER THINKING
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS.
PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL IN THE
REAR CHAMBER TO GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
RECOGNIZE SOME SPECIAL GAS FROM
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY WHO ARE
HERE IN.
THE GALLERY WITH US TODAY TODAY
WE ARE PRIVILEGE TO WELCOME TO
THE LEGISLATURE MEMBERS OF
HADASSAH THE WOMEN'S ZIONIST
ORGANIZATION OF AMERICA WE'RE
HERE FOR THEIR ANNUAL ADVOCACY
DAY.
AND FOR OVER A HUNDRED YEARS
HADASSAH HAS WORKED TO EMPOWER
JEWISH WOMEN TO AFFECT CHANGE TO
CONNECT TO ISRAEL AND TO BRING
HEALING AND JUSTICE TO THE WORLD.
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY CHAPTER
FOR DOS HAS OVER FOUR THOUSAND
MEMBERS WHO HAVE WOMEN --
PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE IN
IMPROVING OUR COMMUNITY FIGHTING
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND ON SO MANY
OTHER ISSUES MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING THE WOMEN OF HER
DAUGHTER FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY TO THE ASSEMBLY
. EIGHT
AND MISTER BLOOM YOU HAVE A
SPECIAL GUEST IN THE CAME TODAY
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU AND
HAPPY NEW YEAR MISTER SPEAKER
AND EVERYONE THAT IT IS MY HONOR
TO INTRODUCE ONE OF THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES IS.
GREAT COUNCIL MEMBERS THERE ARE
MANY GREAT COUNCIL MEMBERS BUT
OF COURSE THE BEST ARE THOSE
THAT ARE CROSSED THAT CROSS OVER
MY DISTRICT.
I REPRESENT ABOUT A QUARTER OF A
MILLION AYE AYE ANGELENOS I'M
VERY PROUD OF THAT AND WE'RE
VERY HAPPY TO WELCOME COUNCIL
MEMBER DAVID DREW OF LOS ANGELES
IS FOURTH CALVET MANIC DISTRICT
.
MEMBERS I SEE A FORM US.
AND CURRENT MEMBER OF THE UNITED
STATES HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
TOADY PARDONS HAS JOINED US ON
THE FLOOR.
AUGUST MEMBER CARD AND
MEMBERS
I'D ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE A
FORMER MEMBER OF THIS HOUSE IN
CURRENT.
CONGRESS MEMBER.
JIM COSTA HAS JOINED US ON THE
FLOOR.
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE A
FORMER MEMBER OF THIS HOUSE AS
WELL AS THE UPPER HOUSE IN THIS
[inaudible]
BUILDING.
THE HONORABLE IS IN OUR HALL
[inaudible]
MR HOLLISTER.
MEMBERS PLEASE DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE REAR THE
CHAMBER TO MY GAS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE.
MISTER LEVINE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FROM MY DESK ON THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS CALIFORNIANS
FROM ACROSS THE STATE.
HAVE DESCENDED UPON OUR CAPITAL
TODAY AND IT IS NO SURPRISE TO
ME WE'RE HERE TO RECOGNIZE THE
ONE AND ONLY PHYLLIS CHAO.
IT'S IT'S TRULY HER DAY WE ARE
HONORING THIS AMAZING WOMAN AN
OFFERING OUR HEARTFELT
CONGRATULATIONS.
ON A WELL EARNED RETIREMENT.
BUT I'D FORGIVE YOU IF YOU
DIDN'T KNOW THAT SHE RETIRED ON
DECEMBER.
TWENTY EIGHT IN FACT I OH WILL
TO EMAILS FROM PHYLLIS ABOUT
SCHEDULING REQUESTS ON NEW
YEAR'S MORNING.
GET THIS ON FRIDAY SHE WAS IN MY
OFFICE ON HER BIRTHDAY AFTER
RETIREMENT.
IT'S NO SURPRISE AFTER ALL
PHYLLIS CHOW IS THE BEST.
AGAIN IN THE LEGISLATURE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY IT WAS JUST LIKE
YESTERDAY JERRY BROWN WAS
GOVERNOR.
BUT THERE WERE SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCES JIMMY CARTER WAS
PRESIDENT.
AND IF YOU REMEMBER TYPEWRITERS
THEY TOOK UP VALUABLE REAL
ESTATE A TOP OUR TESTS.
WE HAVE PHOTOS.
AFTER GRADUATING FROM UCLA
PHYLLIS JOIN THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE STAFF HE THEN WORK FOR
SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEMPORE
EIGHT JAMES MILLS IN SAN DIEGO
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO SHE
RETURNED TO THE CAPITAL. TO
BECOME SCHEDULER FOR SENATOR
GARY HART.
EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR SHE THEN
WORKED WITH SENATORS AND NOW
CONGRESSMAN ACOSTA DO CHENEY AND
HE IN TWO THOUSAND TEN PHYLLIS
TOOK TWO YEARS. TO CARE FOR HER
MOTHER IN LOS ANGELES WHEN SHE
RETURNED TO SACRAMENTO TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE SHE RESUMED HER
CAREER.
WITH SENATOR CORBETT UNTIL
TWENTY FOURTEEN WHEN SHE JOINED
OF MY OFFICE.
AND CHANGE MY LIFE.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO WHEN PHIL
SUPPLIED WORK FOR SENATOR HEART
SHE WAS INTERVIEWED AND HIRED BY
CHIEF OF STAFF JERRY SEE BOARD
IS RIGHT HERE WITH US IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR JERRY AND
PHYLLIS WERE DELEGATES TO THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL CONVENTION
IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AFTER JERRY LEFT SACRAMENTO BE
KEPT IN TOUCH AND REMAIN FRIENDS
FOR THIRTY YEARS.
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN PHYLLIS
AND JERRY HAD DINNER TOGETHER TO
SUPPORT EACH OTHER IN CARING FOR
THEIR ELDERLY PARENTS.
AND SOMETHING JUST CLICKED THEY
BEGIN DATING AND IN TWENTY SIX
SIXTEEN THEY MERRY [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
WHEN?
AFTER NEARLY FORTY YEARS OF
PUBLIC SERVICE THERE IS JUST SO
MUCH TO SAY WE ALL KNOW FILL AS
POSSIBLY THE BEST.
SHOT TO EVER WORK IN THE CAPITAL.
MY DAUGHTER WARNED ME THAT IF I
LISTED ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
FOODS SHE HAD MADE THAT IT WOULD
GO SO LONG YOU WOULD START
DAYDREAMING OF UNICORNS.
PHYLLIS IS FOOD BRINGS PEOPLE
TOGETHER.
BILLS PROVIDE COMFORT
INSTABILITY IN A STRESSFUL IN
CHALLENGING ENVIRONMENTS AND HER
FOOD WAS NOT JUST FOR MY OFFICE.
IT WAS SHARED WITH ALL.
IF YOU WORK ON THE FIFTH FLOOR
YOU KNEW THERE WAS SOMETHING
GOOD IN MY OFFICE FOR PRACTICE
THAT DAY BY THE SCENT OF FRESH
BAKED DELICIOUSNESS IN THE AIR.
BUT PHYLLIS IS SO MUCH MORE THAN
A CULINARY DELIGHTS.
NEW MEMBERS ARE OFTEN TOLD THAT
THE MOST IMPORTANT HIGHER IS A
SCHEDULER.
THE ACT AS THE GATE FOR
SCHEDULERS HAVE TO SAY NO TO A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
EXCEPT MY WIFE.
TWENTY BILL ALWAYS KNEW WHO HAD
THE LAST WORD ON MY CALENDAR IT
IS A VERY DIFFICULT JOB.
BUT WHEN PHYLLIS HOW TO SAY NO
TO A MEETING SHE DID IT WITH
COURTESY AND A GENUINE ATTEMPT
TO FIND A SOLUTION.
PHYLLIS CAN DELIVER BAD NEWS AND
MAKE IT FEEL WONDERFUL INCLUDING
WHAT SHE TOLD ME SHE WAS GOING
TO RETIRE.
IF FOR PHYLLIS HER KINDNESS
GENEROSITY AND SELFISHNESS
CREATE A POSITIVE AND SUPPORTIVE
ENVIRONMENT.
THAT MAKES US ALL FEEL SAFE.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
OFTEN SERVES AS A SOUNDING BOARD
FOR YOUNG STAFF.
ESPECIALLY WOMEN IN A PLACE
TRADITIONALLY DOMINATED BY MEN.
ADVICE IS ALWAYS SYMPATHETIC
ALWAYS STAFFEL INSENSIBLE.
THIS CELEBRATE ALL THE GOOD
THINGS IN LIFE.
FAMILY FRIENDS CO WORKERS ALL OF
TO ENJOY LIFE IN THE MOMENT.
WHILE ALSO KNOWING THAT SHE IS
MAKING MEMORIES.
SHE KEEPS IN TOUCH WITH PEOPLE
SHE IS KNOWN AND WORKED WITH
OVER THE LAST FORTY YEARS MANY
OF WHOM ARE UP IN THE GALLERY WE
SEE YOU GUYS UP THERE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING PART OF
TODAY.
SHE MAKES A GENUINE EFFORT TO
STAY IN TOUCH GETTING TOGETHER
FOR STAFF FOR UNIONS HOSTING
BARBECUES AND GOING THE EXTRA
MILE TO KEEP HER FRIENDSHIPS
FLOOR SHEEN.
I CANNOT OVERSTATE HOW MUCH
PHYLLIS CHAO IS LOVED BY THE
CAPITAL COMMUNITY. TO THE TV
SETS THROUGHOUT THE BUILDING.
WE LOVE.
WHEN I FIRST HIRED HER I WAS
TOLD PHYLLIS IS LIKE FAMILY?
BE -- YOU
HAVE HIRED AN AMAZING PERSON BE
SUPER NICE TO HER.
THIS IS SO TRUE SO SO TRUE.
I KNEW THIS DAY WOULD COME AND
I'M HONORED THAT PHYLLIS CHOSE
TO SPEND THE LAST YEARS OF HER
WORKING CAREER ON BEHALF OF MY
CONSTITUENTS ENSURING THE PAST
FOUR YEARS I HAVE FELT.
HER LOVE IN SO MANY WAYS.
NO YOU ARE RETIRING BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT YOU WILL NOT BE FAR
AWAY.
PLEASE KNOW THAT YOU ARE ALWAYS
WELCOME IN MY OFFICE IN IN MY
HOME.
YOU FOR DEDICATING YOUR AMAZING
CAREER TO PUBLIC SERVICE WE WISH
YOU AND JERRY JOYFUL CONTENTMENT
IN RETIREMENT AND PHYLLIS WE
LOVE YOU
.
MR LEVINE YEAR AGAIN RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU WERE HAVING A LITTLE
CELEBRATION WITH SOME FOOD AND
CATERING UP IN ROOM THREE
SEVENTEEN AFTER SESSION AND
PROBABLY BEFORE SESSIONS OUT FOR
EVERYONE UP IN THE GALLERY AND
FROM THE BUILDING THAT WANTS TO
JOIN.
AND CELEBRATE WITH PHYLLIS TODAY
PLEASE JOIN US THANK YOU
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE MORE SPECIAL
GAS INTRODUCTION.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO MR CHOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES --
IT IS --
INDEED AN HONOR FOR MEDIA
INTERVIEWS ON BEHALF OF THE
SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY CHINESE
COUNSEL GENERAL OF LOS ANGELES --
TOPPING AND A DEPUTY COUNSEL
GENERAL IN SAN FRANCISCO MISTER
YOUNG HONG TOLL.
PLEASE HELP ME WELCOME THEM
[inaudible]
THIS IS
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
AS SUCH I WOULD ASK THAT YOU ALL
TAKE YOUR SEATS PLEASE MEMBERS.
I WOULD ASK THAT YOU TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
OR FIND YOUR DASH.
SIX WE ARE AT A GERMANS IN
MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
THE SPEAKER WILL HAVE AND GERMAN
IN MEMORY MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS
.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WHERE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
I WOULD ASK THE MEMBERS TAKE
THEIR SEATS
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS.
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
ASK THAT THE ASSEMBLY.
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF JUDGE
WILLIAM NEWS AND THE THIRD.
JUDGE NEWSOME DIED LAST MONTH AT
AGE EIGHTY FOUR AT HIS HOME IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
IT IS PARTICULARLY FITTING THAT
WE REMEMBER HIM TODAY.
ON THE DAY THAT HIS SON IS SWORN
IN AS THE FORTY OF THE GOVERNOR
OF THIS AMAZING STATE. FOR SOME
MEN A REMARKABLE CHILD WOULD BE
ENOUGH OF AN ACCOMPLISHMENT.
BUT OF COURSE WILLIAM NEWSOME
ACHIEVED MUCH MORE.
HE WAS THE STARCH IN OF OUR
MENTAL LAWYER IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES.
WHEN THEN GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN
APPOINTED HIM TO THE BENCH OF
PLASTER COUNTY?
JUST A FEW YEARS LATER HE WAS
ELEVATED TO THE COURT OF APPEAL
OUR STATE SECOND HIGHEST COURT.
WHERE IS RULINGS INCLUDED CASES
ON HIV PRIVATE PRIVACY?
LIABILITY FOR ATHLETIC INJURY.
EQUAL EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY AND
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE.
HE MADE A MARK ON CALIFORNIA'S
LAWS AND MADE A MARK ON THE MAN
WHO TODAY.
BECAUSE THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OF
CALIFORNIA'S LAWS.
HE ADMINISTERED THE OATH OF
OFFICE TO GAVIN NEWSOM IS MAYOR
OF SAN FRANCISCO.
AND WE MORE IN THAT HE DID NOT
QUITE LIVE LONG ENOUGH TO
ADMINISTER THE OF GOVERNOR AS
WELL.
TODAY OUR THOUGHTS ARE WITH HIS
SURVIVORS HIS CHILDREN GAVIN AND
HILLARY KNEW SOME.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING IN MEMORY
TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
[inaudible]
MISTER DALLI.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR A
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE.
TODAY TO JOIN A MEMBER A FORMER
REPUBLICAN LEADER GREG BATTLE.
FOR REPUBLICAN LEADER GREG
BUTTLE BORN JULY FOURTH NINETEEN
THIRTY ONE CERTAIN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
FROM.
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR TO NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE AND IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE FROM.
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO TO NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE BUT IT WAS THE
MAJORITY LEADER FROM SIXTY NINE
TO SEVENTY HE PASSED --
IN SEPTEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AFTER A LONG LIFE OF
PUBLIC SERVICE.
WE MOURN HIS PASSING WE WILL
REMEMBER HIM IN OUR PRAYERS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS DELI MISTER
FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF FORMER ASSEMBLY
MAJORITY LEADER TOM HANNIGAN.
TOM PASSED AWAY LAST OCTOBER AND
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE KAREN
CONNELLY.
HIS THREE CHILDREN ERIN MATT AND
BRIDGES.
AS WELL AS SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN.
HE WAS A CALIFORNIA NATIVE.
BORN IN VALLEJO AND GRADUATED
FROM ST PATRICK'S IN VINCENT
HIGH SCHOOL IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT HE ATTENDED
THE UNIVERSITY OF SANTA CLARA.
WHERE HE MET HIS FIRST WIFE JAN?
AND WAS MARRIED IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE HE ENGINE
WERE MARRIED FOR FORTY THREE
MEMORABLE YEARS BEFORE HER
UNTIMELY PASSING.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIX SHORTLY AFTER
GRADUATING FROM SANTA CLARA.
MISTER HANNEGAN JOINED THE
MARINE CORPS AND SERVED A NINE
MONTH TOUR.
OF DUTY IN VIETNAM.
AFTER HIS RETURN THàNH GOT
INVOLVED IN THE REAL ESTATE
BUSINESS AND OPENED HIS OWN
OFFICE.
HANNIGAN AND ASSOCIATES.
BUT IT WAS PUBLIC SERVICE THAT
WOULD BECOME HIS LIFE'S CALLING.
BEGINNING ON THE FAIRFIELD CITY
COUNCIL FROM NINETEEN SEVENTY TO
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR WHERE HE
WAS MAYOR FOR TWO OF THOSE FOUR
YEARS.
HE WAS ELECTED TO THE SOLANO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOR SERVING AS
A DISTRICT THREE SUPERVISOR
UNTIL.
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT HE WAS
ELECTED THE STATE ASSEMBLY IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT ALSO.
AND REPRESENTING THE FOURTH IN
THE EIGHT DISTRICTS.
HE WAS SERVING THE ASSEMBLY
UNTIL.
NINETEEN NINETY SIX INCLUDING
NEARLY A DECADE AS THE MAJORITY
LEADER.
THE LONGEST TENURE IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY.
TOM HAVE A CAN WAS A STAUNCH
ADVOCATE AND CHAMPION FOR WATER
DEVELOPMENT.
AND PROTECTION OF THE DELTA.
HE WAS ALSO INSTRUMENTAL IN
HELPING SECURE MANY OF THE
INTERSTATE EIGHTY IMPROVEMENTS
IN THE EIGHTIES AND THE NINETIES.
AS WELL AS THE AMTRAK CAPITOL
CORRIDOR SERVICE CONNECTED
CONNECTING SOLANO. TO THE BAY
AREA.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HANNIGAN WAS
KNOWN AS A MAN OF IMMENSE AND
INTELLECT AND INTEGRITY.
AND AS FORMER SENATE PRO TEM
JOHN BURTON DESCRIBED HIM.
HE WAS ONE KIND OF A G. D.
DECENT MAN.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I'D DURING
MEMORY.
SOME FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER TOM
AND CAN [inaudible]
MR GRAYSON.
MISTER SPEAKER AND FELLOW
MEMBERS I TO RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF FORMER MAJORITY LEADER
TOM HANNIGAN.
IS PUBLIC SERVICE IS RESPECTED
REPUTATION ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
POLITICAL AISLE AND IS
MENTORSHIP OF FUTURE LEADERS.
HAS BEEN A HUGE INSPIRATION TO
MANY. TWO YEARS AGO WHEN HIS
DAUGHTER ERIN WAS NAMED ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FOURTEENS WOMAN OF THE
YEAR TOM PLAYFULLY REMINDED ME.
THAT THE DAILY COMMUTE ABOARD
THE CAPITAL QUARTER TRAIN WAS
MADE POSSIBLE BY HIS ARD WORK
AND PERSEVERANCE.
AND IT HAS SINCE BECOME ONE OF
THE BEST PERFORMING AMTRAK
CORRIDORS IN THE COUNTRY.
WITH THIS AND MUCH MORE TOM
LEAVES AS A REMINDER OF WHAT CAN
BE ACHIEVED THROUGH A LIFE OF
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVICE I ASKED
YOU JOIN ME IN A JOURNEY AND
MEMORY OF TOM HIM.
THANK WHICH GRAYSON.
AND MR COOLEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I ALSO WANT OR STAND
IN RECOGNITION OF TOM HAND
AGAINST PASSING [inaudible]
ARM.
AS HAS BEEN SAID HE WAS IN THE
MARINE CORPS.
SO HE'S IN THAT CLASS OF MEMBERS
WHO SERVE HERE ACTUALLY SERVED
IN VIETNAM.
AND OF COURSE IN MILITARY
SERVICE AS MY KIDS TEACHERS
OFTEN SAY --
IF YOU STICK YOUR HEAD OUT OF
YOUR FOXHOLE THAT'S WHEN YOU GET
SHOT AT AND I THINK THAT'S
ACTUALLY A WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
TOM HANNIGAN.
AND A WHOLE CONCEPT OF PUBLIC
SERVICE.
FROM THE SEVENTIES AND FAIRFIELD.
THE MID SEVENTIES ON THE CITY
COUNCIL A LECTERN SEVENTY EIGHT
THAT'S THE YEAR THAT THIS.
THIS HOUSE LOST ITS SUIT IT'S
TWO THIRDS MAJORITY.
SEVENTY EIGHT THAT WAS YOUR PROP
THIRTEEN THE TAX REVOLT.
SO TOM HANNIGAN IN PUBLIC
SERVICE COMING OUT A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
ARRIVE WITH THE EXPOSURE PROP
THIRTEEN THE TAX REVOLT.
CAME HERE AND HAD TO LEARN HOW
TO BE A STATE LAWMAKER.
IN A TIME WHEN.
CALIFORNIA BODY POLITIC WAS
SHARPLY DIVIDED ON THAT TAX
ISSUE.
TOM WAS A WAS A REAL THOUGHTFUL
INDIVIDUAL COURSE HE SERVES A
CHAIR REVENUE TAX. FOR YEAR
AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR.
THEN BECOMING MAJORITY LEADER.
AND I CAN SAY YOU KNOW HE'S THAT
PERSON IS FOR PERSONIFIES WHAT
WE YOU'VE ALL HEARD THE LINE
ABOUT THE DOC.
WHO IS PADDLING FURIOUSLY ACROSS
THE LAKE BUT LOOK SO SERENE ON
TOP?
SOMEHOW HE MANAGED. TO POKE HIS
HEAD IN THE PUBLIC SERVICE. TO
BE IN A TIME OF CONTENTIOUS
ISSUES.
AND YET RETAIN A CALM ABOUT
HIMSELF AND HIS WORK.
AND TO PERSEVERE.
IN PUBLIC SERVICES TO HAVE CELLS
AND REPUTATION.
SO I JUST THINK.
I WANNA STAND BECAUSE ACTUALLY
DO REMEMBER TOM HANNIGAN.
WATCHING HIM WORK IN THIS
BUILDING THE CALM HE EXHIBITED
IN THE FACE OF CONTENTIOUS TIMES.
AND GREAT ROLE MODELS TO REFLECT
UPON -- AS
WE JUST HONOR HIM IS PASSING.
M. IS AG HERE HURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MISTER SPEAKER I TO
RISE TODAY IN HONOR OF TOM HIM
AGAIN.
HE WAS TRULY A GREAT PUBLIC
SERVANT BUT ENDED IN ADDITION TO
THAT HE WAS A MAN WHOSE FAMILY
MEANT MORE TO HIM THAN ANYTHING
ELSE.
HE LEAVES BEHIND A LEGACY OF
DEEP LOVE.
TOM SHOULD TOM LOVE SHARING THE
NAPE NATURE THE OUTDOORS TRAVEL
ADVENTURES WITH THOSE WHO MET
MOST HIM HIS FAMILY.
MY FRIEND SOLANO COUNTY
SUPERVISOR AARON HANNIGAN SPOKE
ABOUT HER FATHER AS OUR BIGGEST
SUPPORTER.
WHEN SHE ANNOUNCED HER DECISION
TO RUN FOR VALLEJO CITY COUNCIL
HE WAS THERE EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY?
IN FACT ONE OF HIS LAST PIECE
SPEAKING ENGAGEMENTS WAS A FILL
IN FOR ERIN WHEN DEALING EVENTS
PREVENTED HER FROM PARTICIPATING
AS A CONTENT CONSTITUENT EVENT.
ONE OF HIS SPEAKING GAMERS WAS
ACTUALLY REPRESENTING HIS
DAUGHTER AT THE EVENT AND SPOKE
HIGHLY AND EVERYBODY GOT A BIG
KICK THAT ERIN WAS NO LOT WASN'T
THERE BUT HE WAS GOING TO THE
LAST.
A CONVERSATION FOR HER.
AS TOM'S SON MATTHEW REMEMBERED
HIM SELECTION OF THE SAYING 90%
OF LIFE IS JUST SHOWING UP AND
BEING PRESENT AND AVAILABLE TO
OTHERS. FOR TOM THAT WAS SO MUCH
MORE THAN JUST SHOWING UP OR
BEING OR SHOWING UP OR BEING OF
AVAILABLE SO TO HONOR TOM HIM
AGAIN.
I HOPE WE WILL ALL REMEMBER TO
BE PRESENT AND AVAILABLE TO
OTHERS IN THE SAME VERY
MEANINGFUL WAY THAT HE WAS.
THANK YOU MS SAGER CURRY.
I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
GALLAGHER.
FOLLOWED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DALLY MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES.
IT IS WITH GREAT SADNESS.
THEN SHARED GRIEF WITH MY
COMMUNITY THAT I HAVE TO REPORT
OF YET ANOTHER.
TRAGIC WILDFIRE CLAIMING THE
LIVES AND PROPERTY [inaudible]
OF CALIFORNIANS.
AFTER THE TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN FIRES I THINK WE ALL
HOPED IT COULDN'T GET ANY WORSE
[inaudible]
IT HAS.
I NEVER COULD FATHOM.
THE MY DISTRICT WOULD BE THE
SITE OF THE DEADLIEST WILDFIRE
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY. EIGHTY
SIX PEOPLE HAVE.
DIED IN OVER SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
STRUCTURES [inaudible]
DESTROYED.
THE COMMUNITIES OF CON CAL
PARADISE CHEROKEE YANKEE HILL.
IN THE GALIA HAVE BEEN DECIMATED.
THIS FAR FASTER THAN ANYONE
COULD IMAGINE.
START IN A REMOTE AREA OFF THE
HIGHWAY SEVENTY ENTERING THAT
WAS EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO REACH
[inaudible]
BY FIREFIGHTERS.
WAS QUICKLY BROUGHT BLOWN BY
FIFTY MILE AN HOUR WINDS.
IN WITHIN TWO SHORT HOURS HAD
BLAZED THROUGH THE COMMUNITY OF
CONCHOLOGY JUMP TO CANYONS.
IT WAS ALREADY LIGHTING FIRES IN
THE COMMUNITY OF PARADISE.
RESPOND OR IS HAVE LIKENED IT
INTO A FLAME THROWER THAT SHOT
FIERY EMBERS.
UP TO A MILE FROM THE FIRE LINE.
BEGIN A NEW SPOT FIRES WHICH IN
TURN WERE BLOWN EVEN FURTHER
DOWN WHEN.
MY COMMUNITY IS EXPERIENCE PURE
TERROR.
THE STORIES OF WHAT HAS BEEN
INJURED.
BY SO MANY WAS PURE HELL ON
EARTH.
SURROUNDED BY FLAMES HAVING TO
ABANDON CARS AND LITERALLY RUN.
FOR THEIR LIVES.
BUT THERE HAVE ALSO BEEN STORIES
OF AMAZING COURAGE.
AND GRACE UNDER PRESSURE.
PEOPLE HELPING ONE ANOTHER
ESCAPE.
ENCOURAGING ONE ANOTHER.
THEY WOULD GET THROUGH THIS.
FLAMES STOPPING AT THE FOOT OF A
CHURCH.
LAWN FORSMAN IN FIREFIGHTERS
NURSES.
PUTTING THEMSELVES IN HARM'S WAY
TO EVACUATE RESIDENTS.
BULLDOZERS THAT MIRACULOUSLY
CAME AT THE RIGHT MOMENT. TO
PUSH CARS OUT OF THE WAY.
SO THAT LIVES WERE SAVED.
TODAY WE PRAY FOR GRIEVE WITH
THESE FAMILIES THAT HAVE LOST
LOVED ONES [inaudible]
THEIR HOMES [inaudible]
EVERYTHING.
WE ASK GOD TO BRING THEM PEACE.
AND IN TIME.
THE STRENGTH TO REBUILD.
WE ARE THANKFUL FOR THE MANY
FIREFIGHTERS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS WHO KEPT US SAFE.
AND BATTLED THE FLAMES.
THE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
OFFICIALS IN THE NONPROFIT
CHARITIES.
WHO ARE HELPING US RECOVER?
WE ALSO THANK YOU FOR THE LOVING
HEARTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA IN THE
NATION.
AND THE WORLD.
WHOSE AID WAS IMMEDIATE AND
STEADFAST THROUGH THIS TIME.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT WE CANNOT
CONTROL.
YOU CAN'T CONTROL.
WHERE THE WIND BLOWS?
WE ARE FINITE.
AT THE MERCY.
OF A NATURE THAT CONTINUES TO
GROWN UNDER CORRUPTION.
BUT WE ASK THE LORD'S HELP FOR
THE THINGS THAT WE CAN CHANGE.
OUR UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE IS
OUTDATED.
AND DANGEROUS.
WE NEEDED EXTENSIVE FUEL
MANAGEMENT IN OUR FOR US IN OUR
WILD LANDS.
ARMORED NC ALERT SYSTEMS CAN AND
MUST BE IMPROVED.
WE MUST BUILD MORE RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES.
AND BETTER ROADWAYS IN AND OUT
OF FIRE ZONES.
LORD GIVE US THE WISDOM IN THE
DISCERNMENT. TO MAKE GOOD POLICY
DECISIONS THAT WILL SAVE LIVES.
IN AVOID TRAGEDY IN THE FUTURE.
AND HELP US TO KNOW.
BUT ALL THINGS ARE POSSIBLE
THROUGH CHRIST WHO STRENGTHENS
US.
AND THERE ARE ROCK [inaudible]
OUR HOPE.
IS THAT YOU ARE BUILDING A
KINGDOM.
AND THE GATES OF HELL SHALL NOT
STAND AGAINST IT.
NOW I ASK THAT WE READ THE NAMES.
OF THE FALLEN IN THAT WE ADJOURN
OUR SESSION TODAY.
IN THEIR HONORED MEMORY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK A MISH GALLAGHER BEFORE WE
DO THAT I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
MISTER DALLI MISTER DALLI YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I ALSO RISE WITH MY FRIEND FROM
THE SICK LIST TO REPRESENTS THE
THIRD ASSEMBLY DISTRICT MOST OF
THE DEVASTATION FROM THE FROM
THE CAMPFIRE WAS IN --
GALLAGHER'S DISTRICT I REPRESENT
REGALIA WERE IT WASN'T QUITE AS
SEVERE --
BUT I JUST WANT TO DROP PICTURE
FREE REAL QUICK FIRST I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE MEMBERS WHO
REACHED OUT TO US AND IN THE END
SO MANY OF YOU CALLED SIT.
MONEY IN AND HELP OUR
COMMUNITIES --
WE'RE GONNA BE IN FOR THE LONG
HAUL AMIDST WANNA.
PAID A LITTLE BIT A PICTURE OF
WHAT THE COMMUNITY LOOKS LIKE SO
YOU YOU KIND OF GET AN IDEA.
EVERYTHING YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT
YOU HAVE SERVICES FOR IN YOUR
CITY ARE GONE.
WHAT PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO FIND
DEATH CERTIFICATES AT THE CITY
HALL OR FIND --
MAPS THERE'S ALL IT'S COMPLETELY
GONE THERE IS NOTHING THERE THE
POST OFFICE IS GONE EVERYTHING
THAT YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT YOU
WOULD ACTUALLY GO TO TO TO GET
SERVICES IS NO LONGER THERE.
IT IS INCREDIBLY SAD IT'S IT
LOOKS LIKE A WAR ZONE WHERE A
NUCLEAR BOMB WENT OFF.
AND WE'RE GONNA BE SOMETIME --
TO BRING THAT COMMUNITY BACK TO
LIVE IS NOT AS A IT'S A LOT
DIFFERENT THAN THE THEN THE THE
CAR THE CAR FIRE WHICH WAS IN MY
DISTRICT.
EARLIER THIS YEAR WE LOST SEVEN
LIVES USE ARE STILL A COMMUNITY
THERE.
SO I JUST WANT TO ALSO STAND
WITH THE EXTRA GALLAGHER AND IT
IS VERY SAD WE LOST THESE LIVES --
AND I WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS
AND I WANT TO TAKE THE REST OF
THE PEOPLE WHO REACHED OUT TO US.
TO TRY -- TO
THE SOME OF THE PAINT AND
HUMANKIND IS EVEN IN THIS
TRAGEDY HAS BEEN JUST
OVERWHELMING SO.
THAT MAY GOD BLESS THE FAMILIES
THAT HAVE LOST LOVED ONES.
IN A MAYBE --
HOPEFULLY REBUILD THAT COMMUNITY
SOMETIME SOON.
THANK YOU MISTER DALLI AND THANK
YOU MISTER GALLAGHER THE CLERK
WILL NOW READ THE NAMES OF THE
VICTIMS OF THE CAMPFIRE
[inaudible]
CHOICE ACHESON [inaudible]
THERESA AMMAN'S [inaudible]
RAFAEL ANDRADE [inaudible]
CAROL ARLINGTON.
JULIAN BEEN STOCK.
DAVID BRAD BIRD [inaudible]
RICHARD BROWN [inaudible]
JERRY BROWN [inaudible]
ANDREW BURT [inaudible]
JOANNE CADDY [inaudible]
BARBARA CARLSON [inaudible]
DENNIS CLARK [inaudible]
JOHN DIGBY [inaudible]
GORDON DIS [inaudible]
PAULA DODGE [inaudible]
RANDALL DODGE [inaudible]
ANDREW DOWNER [inaudible]
ROBERT DUVALL [inaudible]
ROSE FERAL.
HIS USE FERNANDEZ.
JEAN FURS MAN [inaudible]
ERNEST BOSS [inaudible]
ELIZABETH CALL [inaudible]
SALLY GAMBOA [inaudible]
JAMES GARNER [inaudible]
DENNIS HANKO [inaudible]
JENNIFER HAYES [inaudible]
CRISTINA HALFORD [inaudible]
WHO HERRERA [inaudible]
EVA HOLDS.
T. QUE HA [inaudible]
GARY HUNTER [inaudible]
RICHARD J. [inaudible]
DOROTHY MAC [inaudible]
SERRA MAGNUSON [inaudible]
JOANNE MALARKEY [inaudible]
JOHN MALARKEY [inaudible]
DAVID MARBURY.
DEBORAH MORNING STAR
[inaudible]
HELEN PACE [inaudible]
JOY PORTER [inaudible]
BEVERLY POWERS.
JOSEPH RAP TôI [inaudible]
FORREST RAHA [inaudible]
BERNICE REAGAN.
FEDERAL CELLS ARE [inaudible]
SHEILA SANTOS.
JOHN SAID WAKE [inaudible]
DON SHORES [inaudible]
LARRY SMITH [inaudible]
RUSSELL STEWART [inaudible]
VICTORIA TAFT [inaudible]
SURELY TAY'S [inaudible]
JOAN TRACY [inaudible]
ALAN WALKER [inaudible]
DONNA WHERE. THREE WE ARE
[inaudible]
KIMBER WHERE.
CARL WHY LEE [inaudible]
DAVID YOUNG.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS PLEASE STAND.
ENJOYING AND A MOMENT OF SILENCE.
FOR THE VICTIMS
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS.
TUESDAY JANUARY EIGHTH CHECK IN
SESSION.
WEDNESDAY JANUARY NINTH CHECK IN
THURSDAY JANUARY TENTH FLOOR
SESSION IS AT NINE AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASS AND RETAIN ALL MOTIONS
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SECONDARY NO FURTHER BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN MISTER CALDERON MOVES
AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS THAT
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY JANUARY TENTH AT
NINE AM.
IN THE FORM CALL IS LIFTED